Hank: Good morning, John.
John: Good morning, Hank.
It's time for the Quadragocon.
Hank: How are you liking your chances?
John: Uh, medium.
I mean, if I were up against anyone but you,
I wouldn't like them at all.
[Hank laughs]
[Montage set to T-Shirt and Jeans by Hank
Green]
Hank: [laughs] Too scared.
[Chariots of Fire theme plays]
Hank: I don't really know how croquet works.
John: I think you just go through the wickets.
OK, not bad.
Hank: [laughs] You missed, huh?
It's my turn now.
No.
John: No, no, no.
Hank: My turn now.
John: Hold on.
Hank: You hit the ball and nothing happened.
Oh, and you got both.
John: That's what I wanted to do.
Hank: You look like a dork.
Oh, that's through.
John: That's not through.
Nope!
Hank: Oh!
John: No!
[Montage set to The Universe is Weird by Hank
Green]
Hank: Scott Westerfeld suggested a spitting
contest.
I'm not going to spit, spit though, 'cause
it's gross.
These have spittable things in them.
Apple seeds.
[Spitting noises]
Hank: Next round: typing quiz.
Who types fastest?
John: I feel pretty confident.
Hank: I also don't- do not feel good about
this round.
[Typing noises]
John: I'm usually at over 100, but I've had
a few drinks.
Good luck to you, Hank.
Hank: Okay.
John: Alright, go.
[Typing noises]
John: Three, two, one, I've got him right
at the end.
He's 65!
Hank: Oh, oh, oh, oh God.
Hank from the future here.
The first event in the Quadragocon, as we
said in John's video, was the Blue Steel competition,
and when we filmed this stuff, John's video
hadn't been uploaded yet, so we didn't know
who had won the Blue Steel competition.
Well, it turns out, thank you all very much,
I did.
I, by, like, a two-to-one margin, at least,
so I'm going to go ahead and give myself another
point, and we're going to play the last event
in the Quadragocon.
John: Are you good at pool or bad?
Hank: I am not good.
John: I'm also not good, so-
Hank: Okay, good, perfect.
[Sound of hitting pool balls]
John: Oh, no!
Hank: Hurrr!
Uhhh!
Oh!
John: That's terrible news for me.
Use this tiny little stick and I'm just going
to hit my balls as hard as I can.
[Pool shots]
John: Woo!
Hank: Getting real close here at the end.
John: This is basically all of Quadragocon
probably.
Hank: Uhh!
Oooh!
John: Oh God.
Hank: Oh....
John: Heeeeeyyyyyaaaaah!
Hank: How did that happen?
John: That's my whole strategy is to have
someone else screw up the 8 ball.
Hank: I will say one thing for me that 8 ball
scratch rule, it's not a real rule, it's just
a rule that we've always happened to play
by.
If we're going with the actual official rules
the thing I did was not the end of the game.
But as brothers we have always played that
if you scratch off the 8 ball you lose the
game.
So anyway, that was Quadragocon 2015.
I guess I don't mind tying with you John.
I mean I do a little bit.
It was really great to spend some time with
you and the family and to do some stuff together,
I miss you already, and I'll see you on Tuesday.
Because I wanted one a lot, for the next week
you can pre-order a Quadragocon 2015 shirt
and then never again so that's something that
you can do.
John: Oh my God!
Hank: What!
What!
Uno points for style.